comment améliorer les déplacements des
personnes à mobilité réduite d'abord en
organisant l'espace urbain à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines par exemple
sur 400 km de voirie
16082 obstacles précisément ont été
recensés ensuite en proposant de
nouvelles technologies des étudiants et
des chercheurs de l'ESTACA école
d'ingénieurs qui viendra s'implanter à
Montigny dans deux ans ont présenté leur
production lors d'un premier colloque à
l'image de ce tricycle qui peut se plier
en mode déambulatoire un travail étalé
sur trois mois la difficulté était que
le tricycle correspondent aux dimensions
du quai des charges afin que on puisse
utiliser pour passer dans des portes ou
pour aller au supermarché c'est surtout
ça la grande difficulté c'est un peu un
projet qui est très proche d'un projet
professionnel donc c'était ce qui était
intéressant puisque on était en sortant
un peu des études on pouvait enfin
penser à un produit qui pourrait
peut-être être vendu plus tard autre
projet le développement d'une assistance
électrique pour fauteuil roulant fournir
une assistance un fauteuil roulant quand
on pousse on sent qu'on est un petit peu
aidé et quand on recule on sent qu'on a
un petit peu aidé aussi donc
effectivement d'un point de vue
fonctionnel c'est pas forcément pas très
compliqué après quand on rentre dans les
détails il s'agit de faire une mesure
d'effort rien qu'une mesure des forces
c'est pas forcément quelque chose qui
est évident ce qui fait la complexité
d'un projet comme celui-là c'est un peu
le moment où on regroupe toutes les
briques qu'on a vu en cours voilà et
puis le temps aussi qui fait que c'est
court et c'est voilà c'est ce qui fait
que les projets sont intéressants des
innovations présentées en partenariat
avec le Centre d'études sur la mobilité
et le handicap le CRM a été développé
dans le cadre du pôle de compétitivité
mauvais eau implanté à Versailles les
problèmes posés par les personnes à
mobilité réduite sont source de
réflexion qui peuvent amener à la au
développement de produits de services
qui en plus sont rendre service au grand
public également mais pour acquérir ces
innovations technologiques qu'il faudra
faire preuve de patience au moins trois
ou quatre ans